nuclear power as it currently stands so
using a fission uh is extremely safe
despite public perception it is the
safest actually so that's a whole nother
conversation but almost like a human
bureaucratic
physics
engineering uh question of what lessons
do you draw from the
um
catastrophic events where they uh the
the pot plants did fail so Chernobyl and
Three Mile Island Chernobyl what lessons
do you draw three ball Island wasn't
really a disaster because nothing
escaped from nothing but Chernobyl and
Fukushima were have been you know had
consequences in the populations and that
live nearby what lesson do you draw from
those that you can carry forward to
Fusion now I know there's you can say
that you're not going to have the same
kind of issues but it's possible that
the same folks also said they're not
going to be have those same kind of
issues yeah we humans the human factor
we haven't talked about that one quite
as much but it's still there so to be
clear it's so Fusion has the intrinsic
safety with respect to it can't run away
those are physics bases
Technology and Engineering basis of
running a complex again anything that
makes large amounts of power and heats
things up has got intrinsic safety in it
and by the fact that we actually produce
very energetic particles this doesn't
mean that there's no radiation involved
in ionizing radiation to be more
accurate infusion it's just that it's in
a very different order of magnitude
basically so what are the lessons uh in
in Fusion so so one of them is
make sure that you're looking at aspects
of the holistic environmental and
societal footprint that the technology
will have as technologists we tend not
to focus on these and particularly in
early stages of development like we just
want something that works right but if
we if we come with just something that
works but doesn't actually satisfy the
societal demands for safety and for
dispose I mean we will have materials
that we have to dispose of out of fusion
just this is but there's technological
questions about what that looks like so
will this look like something that you
have to you know put in the ground for
100 years or five years like and the
consequences of those are both economic
and societal acceptance and so forth but
don't bury those like put the bring
these up front talk to people about them
and make people realize that you're
actually you know the way I would look
is that you're making Fusion more
economically attractive by making it
more societally except as well too
and then realize is that you know I
think there's a few interesting you know
boundaries basically this so one of them
speaking of boundaries that successful
Fusion devices I'm pretty sure will
require that you don't have to re have
an evacuation plan for anybody who lives
at the site boundary
so this has this has implications for
what we build from a fusion engineering
point of view but has major implications
for where you can cite Fusion devices
right so in many ways it becomes more
like well you know we have fences around
you know industrial heat sources and
things like this for a reason right for
personal safety it looks more like that
right it's not quite as simple as that
but that's what it should look like and
in fact we have research projects going
on right now at MIT that are like trying
to push the Technologies to make it more
look like that I think that those are
key
and then in the end as I said like so
Chernobyl is physically impossible
actually in an effusion system I'm a
physics from a physics perspective you
can't run away like it did at Chernobyl
which was basically human error that you
know of letting letting the reactors
like run out of control essentially
human error can still happen nuclear
with Fusion basically yeah so but in
that one if human error occurs then it
just stops and this is done and all of
those things this is the requirement of
of us as technologists and and
developers of this technology to not
ignore that dimension in fact of the
design and that's why me personally I'm
actually put pouring myself more and
more into that area because this is
going to be I actually really think it
is an aspect of the economic viability
of fusion because it clearly
differentiates ourselves and also sets
us up to be about what we want Fusion to
be is that again on paper Fusion can
supply all of our energy like all of it
so this means I want it to be like like
really environmentally benign but this
takes engineering Ingenuity basically to
do that